we're gonna have a look at this guy now
there's some really really interesting
things to do with this to begin with
I should probably rewrite it in a form
that shows that they are not there's not
one argument of one fluoroscope like
someone there's really two olives at
play here right how shall i rewrite that
sighs good so this is when you're when
you're taking the question is to write
its subtracting the arguments that's all
you're doing right so I've got this guy
here while I'm rewriting these I might
as well make it could be on what complex
number I've actually compare it to right
so I am right Zed - and what point am i
subtracting 3 plus to my right because
I've got I've got that double negative
in there since what's up already this
one of the angles that I'm interested in
and then he's the other one it's already
written in a nicely fit okay so it's
equal to pi/4
now excuse me II remember that what we
have of depending on what this angle
over here on the right hand side is okay
you can get some very nice neat obvious
things depending on what you see so for
instance just to revise if I had I think
we had these two points right bunch of
bags yeah and if I were comparing the
islands and I want the audience to be
equal which is another way of saying the
difference of the islands is equal to 0
right where my point is going to be do
you remember where you lined up when I
wanted the audience to think you're
gonna be on a out on two reigns aren't
you this way and this way to remember
that because if you stand here you stand
there and you point your compass at both
points you're going to get the saved
bearing Q remember that now in complex
number terms it's actually not that way
you're standing and what your compass is
it's really about what the bags are
measuring to you do you remember that
because you can see this is about tell
me the angle to Zen that's where you are
right you're the locus of points you
were moving from here right so it's
actually the bags who measuring you you
thought you mention the bags the bags
are measuring you but you get the same
effect you cuz look is bag one
the real axis measures up it gets one of
those he's back to it measures up it
also gets the same angle right so these
are the actual arguments I'm interested
in yeah which equates you getting the
same barriers you look at both bags
that's equal to zero
what about if I said pipe what if I one
of the difference between the youngins
2pi yeah it's gonna be on the it's gonna
be the interval between the two points
between the bags do you remember why
good good good
so in case you did yeah think about
where the bags are measuring from and
you remember seeing this right he's the
first bag and it measures its argument
to use its negative principal argument
okay and you get the second bag it's
measuring the same argument here but
when you take the difference between
these two you're gonna be do you see
what's happening right this is a
negative yesterday's so if I was going
from here to here I'm gonna be having
some fun
- that negative one which gives you buy
because they come - yes okay why that
was fine that was four zero and then it
was four pi the second last one I got
should do is play a tune do you remember
when we got with plan - you got a
semicircle right why did we get a simple
what property where we taking about to
tell ya good so be able to say something
is a right Amy like son okay but they're
the last one I got you dude was a real
awkward angle it was something like this
that it was an acute angle okay now this
time let's draw this thing so we can see
what's going on
let's throw away this point is which
already see what it is and then we can
make a comparison
now here are points right now you gotta
be really careful with this yes
it's my because when I guys said take
away a number said take away a number
right that's the number where I'm
measuring from so I'm going said take
away a number and the number is I not
negative I if I wanted to measure from
negative I how would I rewrite what how
I write it would be odd odds in take
away may be negative I that's what I'm
measuring from all right which would be
Z plus I make sense in the same way that
when you've got a circle this is you can
think about it in terms of translation
of coordinates so when you're going to
circle and it's here right
where's the center of this thing and the
answer is negative one right there's a
shift happening but it's the reverse of
what you would think and the whiteboard
is no okay now before I put some lines
onto here okay what circle property like
here see the circle what circle property
am i taking advantage of to map this out
and I wonder if you remember what kind
of shape you traced out okay if I gave
you any two points and 82 points right
and where did you end up standing yeah
you actually spent in two spots think
might remember this kind of shape right
now think about why you had this weird
shape it's not a circle is it okay it's
two major arcs two major arcs it circles
they have the same radius can you see
why you've got why you guys ended up
having both sides do you remember why
what again I'm gonna ask that question
because no one quite has an answer for
ya
what's circle property of my taking
advantage of to know that you guys are
all on an arc yeah
okay so I've really got a full circle
here right which means you've got and on
ya and all of you guys were measuring
out angles
standing on that arc do you remember
that we say the stadium because looks
like two legs okay so you've got one guy
measuring PI on three there or part six
sorry I think it's 30 degrees
you've got another one over here another
one over here and everyone here is
standing on this up the arc it's not
there okay so you've got this kind of
shape it twists out if one doesn't same
angle but there's no reason why you
can't look at the other side right all
these are also going to measure the same
angle out because they're standing on
the same I just flipped around okay does
that make sense but have a look at this
with me right you wouldn't have a look
because here I can tell you right now
you're not going to get two arcs you're
only going to get one the question is
which one okay now I'd like to tell you
just for this example which arc it is
and then we're going to work out why
it's not the other arc okay we're going
to get in this case here if I thought my
numbers right
we're gonna get the top part okay let's
draw it in so we do make a comparison
and then I'll show you I'll try and
convince you why it's not the other way
around
okay so it's not a semicircle it's
something being up like that I don't
know exactly where it is just yet there
are some tools that I'll develop the
mics which will help me next year work
out where exactly that goes but for now
I wished I had the graph I know roughly
where it goes okay now where am I going
to draw my other can be done Young's
right so first let me try to convince
you this is the right one I think if I'm
saying this is my locus right that means
any point on you like saying is a point
it's a point up there okay there's a
particular there and should satisfy this
statement up here when I compare these
two arguments and you one take away the
other I should give play at four okay
where are each of these arguments on my
diagram think carefully
where each of the arguments remember
what I'm saying it's actually not about
where you are where Zedd is and where
it's measure in its compass it's
actually where the bags are right it's
where these two points are and then
measuring up to Z I've got my real axis
Y in parallel my Rea parallel to the
real positive real axis drawn that way
put a measure up to Zed that's going to
be the same
yeah do you agree with that that angle
that I'm just draw their ears this first
angle right I did take away 3 plus 2 I
take away 3 plus gy you came back all
right you're set tell me where the other
argument is what am I gonna have to
construct I'm gonna have to construct
that array right which way which way
where's the ray coming from where's it
going
it starts from I and it's going to the
right isn't it to the positive real axis
like so ok now where's the argument that
it's measuring it's going from I up to
Zen where I'll save Zed shipping ok so
something like this ok so this is my
argument here
this what here okay so that's our dad
buy this spy yeah ok now for this
particular set that I've drawn this
particular is it which evil is bigger
which angle is bigger the right here
they go although that typical the right
head is clearly bigger right in this
case early for this case at the moment
I've got an obtuse angle here and I have
an acute angle over here right so quite
obviously this is bigger than this but
you can see don't cloud your diagram too
badly because it's gonna get pretty busy
even if I have an acute angle over here
we don't I have to put them in order to
get an acute angle over here there's
only a very small pot spot and put it on
right I have to put it there do you see
that that would work ok I could envision
the I'm good that way that's just barely
acute do you see that but it's still
gonna bigger the other one can you see
why you see what when I measure for Y
this will be the key angle here but it's
obviously going to be much smaller
you came with that